هذا العنصر الغذائي القائم بالاساس على
مكون الفلفل ومقادير البهارات المميزه من
كرويه وملح وثوم وزيت الزيتون نجحت تونس
في تسجيل ماده التمثيليه للتراث الثقافيه
اللي هي ملكه
ورجعت لك يعني حاجه بس تعرف بها العالم كل
اللي هريسه هي تونسيه
على الطريق
حيث تشكل الهريسه عنصر اساسا في الثقافه
والمطبخ للعائله التونسيه
هريسه شاي الحمد لله
بمهرجان سنوي يحمل الهريسه وقد مثل
الدورات هذا العيد احد مكونات الملف
المتعلق بالصون والتثمين للهريسه ان شاء
الله ما نبدا احتفلتنا مشكون على طول عم
جي مع وزاره توقفوا مع الفاعلين الكل وان
شاء الله ما نساوي حتى حد ودائما تحاجه
مستقد التاريخ تونس وان شاء الله ننساهم
وزياده كل مره في اضافه عنصر اخر بعد
النجاح في تسجيل الهريسه التونسيه على
قائمه التراث اللام المادي تشرع اليوم
جمعيه صيانه المدينه مع مجموعه من الشركاء
للعمل على بحث مسلك غذائي السياحي تكون
فيه الهريسه منتجه لجذب الرئيس السيسي
نحو التنويع المنتوج السياحي عبر السياحه
الغذائيه وهديه يمشي يكون من خلال زياده
التعريف بروايه غذائيه اخرى معروفه
يعني الهريسه مش تكون ضمن العناصر بتاع
التنميه المستدامه في الجهه الهريسه هي
اول عنصر ثقافيه وطنيه تونسيه وحفظه في
التراث العالمي بعد ان نجحت تونس في تسجيل
فخار سجنا كعنصر ثقافي الجهوي